was that a show or was that a show god
wanda vision was so good and here's the
thing man like the first two episodes
were slow
but i'm so glad i stuck around for the
whole thing i feel like those people who
bailed out with like episode number two
are like this show's boring and dumb i'm
never gonna watch it i feel like they're
feeling it now
right like the whole world is hyped
about the ending of the show and they're
like what wait
what happened no i should have stuck
around for the show
i hope they're feeling it now but uh the
ending of wanda vision yeah man this
show was amazing this show was so good
okay so let's talk about this
post-credits scene with wanda right
because
this is everything right there's so much
in this like if you assuming that
they're gonna do what i think they're
gonna do there's so much in this
post-credits scene that it doesn't it's
not even funny
okay so the first question is where's
wanda at all right i think juan is at
wondergore mountain now if one is at
wonder mountain this is huge for a
couple different reasons the first
is because of the fact that one degor
mountain is basically the home of a guy
by the name of herbert wyndham right
herbert wyndham is also known as the
high evolutionary i don't think we're
going to see him right he does have a
lot of history with wanda but herbert
wyndham is a guy who basically figured
out a way to use technology to
effectively
speed up his evolution the guy is super
powerful where he's super capable but he
really kind of focuses on staying
in one degree mountain doing his own
thing and using what's called his new
men which is basically like artificially
enhanced animals that are basically
given anthropomorphic abilities right so
like think of something like the island
of dr moreau and that's basically what
it is
but the important thing about this is is
the significance of wonder gore mountain
because
herbert windham's not the only person
who occupies that place so one
i was right about the dark hole and this
is important now the reason why it's
important is because over on comics
explain i've got a video where i
explained the dark hole right broke it
down in a super nuanced way i don't know
if any of you guys had a chance to check
that video out yet but it's super
important if you want to understand
the whole significance behind the dark
hold but the dark hold as we know was
written by catholic and catholic wrote
the darkhold when he was on earth and
what would later become
wonder gore mountain in an attempt to
try to bring back a throne and use them
use them for their own ends a sorceress
by the name of morgan le fay
and her followers who were called dark
holders came to the realization that
catholic could not be controlled and so
the only way to
basically keep him from destroying the
world was to lock his essence away in
wonder mountain and assuming we go with
what the hm1 said from like the doctor
strange film there were all kinds of
horrors that were out there
and if she really did do ultimately what
doctor strange did in infinity war
where she had used the time stone to see
what kind of threats were out there and
then nullify those threats before they
became a massive problem it's not beyond
the realm of possibility that the
ancient one had faced off against
cathode at some point in time
and locked him away in wondergore
mountain with the expectation that
nothing would ever come of it now of
course we know that a person cannot see
past their own death and so the ancient
one would never have known that wanda
was going to become the scarlet witch
and that she was going to
effectively unleash cathone inside of
wonderguard mountain because that
happened after the ancient one died
that's one of the things that she
explained
and doctor strange is she can't see past
her own death when she uses
the time stone because she's not alive
so it makes perfect sense
now here's why this matters in this
post-credit scene there was this
scenario where you heard like the kids
of wanda maximoff there's a couple
different ways that you can interpret
this right you could interpret this from
the perspective of
she is kind of experiencing you know a
previous instance where she struggled
like you know kind of remembering the
battle all that kind of stuff it could
be something more metaphorical which is
like the marvel cinematic universe
telling us wanda still struggles with
like her kids and vision and all that
kind of stuff or
it could be cathode messing with her
head and i think that's what's happening
right because one of the things that
agnes said
is that wanda has no idea what she's
unleashed there's precedence for this
right so the important thing to take
away from this is that wanda is what we
call a nexus being right and i'll
comment explain i've got a video
explaining that too right the whole
significance
of nexus beings and why they matter if
you haven't seen that video the long and
short of it is that basically a nexus
being is a person whereby
all mystical energy so magical energy
flows through them
right so essentially the reason why
wanda or at least the reason why agnes
says that wanda's power
exceeds that of doctor strange is
because there are some sources of energy
out there that doctor strange just
cannot access
if he's walking down a hallway of doors
and he's got a key
that key is not going to unlock every
single door so there's some sources of
energy he just can't use
wanda has a master key that's the
benefit of being a nexus being as you
can use
any and all sources of energy that exist
out there that's why she's more powerful
than doctor strange now the important
thing is that with her being on one
degree mountain if she really is a nexus
being like we say she is then that means
that she can do things like access the
multiverse so on and so forth there are
like limits or not really limits but
there are forces out there that exist to
make sure that like a nexus being
doesn't just
run rampant throughout the entire
multiverse so like the time variance
authority the living tribunal they exist
to make make sure that kind of stuff
doesn't happen that like wanna doesn't
screw with the timeline or anything like
that but with all the power that she has
in the end it won't really matter but i
think that with with this being the case
with her basically
stepping into the role quote-unquote of
becoming the scarlet witch i think that
what she's done is initiated something
akin to the eighth day storyline in
marvel comics now those of you guys who
don't know what the eighth day storyline
is it has nothing to do with a scarlet
witch but it does have everything to do
with a guy by the name of sidorak but
the whole idea behind this is that at
some point in the past in marvel there
was a being or a group of people called
the octesans right they were eight
demonic entities and they had made a bet
based on which one of them was the
strongest and so what they did is they
created these different artifacts and
they put them on earth and the first
person to pick up one of those artifacts
would start the eighth day event the
first person to do that in marvel comics
was kane marco when he picked up the
crimson gem of sidorak and became the
juggernaut and what it basically meant
is that
other individuals out there several
other random people would just be pulled
towards these different artifacts that
would ultimately pick them up and then
in effect
humanity would be divided into eight
separate armies those armies would all
go to war against each other and then
whichever army prevailed would prove
that particular demon entity to be the
strongest among all of them i don't
think that's exactly what's happening
but i think that what's happened here is
that by wanda stepping into the role of
the scarlet witch and wanda getting her
hands on the dark hole
and then investigating it that she's
basically set in motion a means by which
cathode will take over her and cathode
will kind of do
his own thing now whether or not this
equates to a great big huge multiversal
contest
i don't know but i do think that it's
something akin to that this is her
equivalent of picking up the crimson gem
of sidorak on earth by the juggernaut
she's effectively set things in motion
this basically means that because she's
now the scarlet witch maybe this is what
cathode was waiting for
right for an individual to pop up who
had an absurd amount of power that
cathode could tap into
and then use that power to move himself
into the earthly plane because here's
the important thing to understand guys
for all the power that agatha had
and all her knowledge of witchcraft and
all that kind of stuff and all the
things that dr strange could do they
have
nothing on cathode absolutely nothing on
this guy it's not even close right
it's not even a contest the fact that
juan is using chaos magic that is a
magic that belongs to catholic he
basically created it literally
all arrows point to the idea that wanda
is in some form or fashion
going to become you know whatever it is
some some harbinger of catholic or
something like that
and that would make perfect sense if the
marvel cinematic universe expands the
role of catholine from just being this
demon that wants to conquer earth and
they turn him into a demon that wants to
conquer all of existence then what
better being to use than a nexus being
themselves somebody who could basically
tap into
other dimensions who can tap into even
the multiverse itself and so if you have
cathone who takes over wanda max them
off and then in turn
sets his sights on conquering the
universe that would happen like that
right in the blink of an eye like the
universe would just be
totally taken over and then from there
it just goes into the multiverse right
and that would make sense if it's called
the multiverse of madness because it
would basically be cathone and wanda
just kind of going through the
multiverse and doing their own thing
because something to understand here
right now
wand is still in an exceedingly
vulnerable state despite all of her
power and all of her abilities
mentally she can still be easily
manipulated because of everything she's
been through and how much she struggles
now i don't know if it'll be exactly
done
like that because the reality is it
would be kind of boring if like you know
she's gone through all of this stuff in
one division which is basically just
like the five stages of grief
right that's basically all the show was
and then in turn she's like taken over
by somebody
else but it would be a really good nod
to a being whose power is just so
astronomical
that there's no real way for wanda to
stand against him again this really all
just kind of comes down to the
interpretation of wanda hearing your
kids voices that catholic really is
confined inside wonder where mountain
and we've seen that play out in marvel
comics right there like the throne can
find inside the mountain his evil
basically permeated the entire land
itself so even the land would basically
manifest in ways that would manipulate
other people it was always a way for
catholic to effectively reach out there
and i think that's cool
i think it's important to bring in this
idea that there are beings out there who
dwarf the power of stephen strange it'd
be a great way to like have the
multiverse of madness to have wanted
touring around the multiverse itself to
have
doctor strange bringing back agnes to
have things like where he pairs up with
baron mordo all that kind of cool stuff
right where it literally takes this kind
of multiversal series of events in order
to somehow bring
wanda down that people have to
effectively come together it'd be a
great swan song because like i've been
saying here
wanda is in effect the marvel cinematic
universe's version of jean grey because
the phoenix and the dark phoenix sagas
that was jean grey swan's song that jean
grey basically stepped into this
enormous amount of power that she was
able to use it for good initially and
then a series of events unfolded whereby
she was effectively corrupted by her
power
due to her emotional state and then went
on a warpath and the only way to bring
that to an end was for her to basically
die and that would make sense if that
was the case with wanda because her
story
goes part and parcel with the story of
jean grey for marvel comics she's a
person who popped up on the scene
she had initial early displays of power
telepathy telekinesis the power that she
had she didn't understand the full
totality of it a situation unfolded
whereby wanda basically came to the
realization of the full amount of power
that she had and then started using it
for her own ends only to discover
that her own emotional state got the
better of her i.e the dark phoenix saga
equivalent in marvel comics she lost her
mind she started using her powers for
nefarious and she was almost compromised
by an enemy which is what you saw happen
to jean grey with mastermind when he
took over her
and then in turn the day was saved but
it basically required her to die in the
process and i think that's exactly
what's gonna happen with wanda that
wanda comes into all this power she
starts messing with the dark hole
not fully understanding what she's
getting into because she's new to all
this
if all you know is there is a book out
there that will help you understand
what your powers are and how to use them
but you don't understand the magical
ties
of that book then it'd be very easy for
an evil for a demonic force that's
exceedingly manipulative
like kathone to ease its way into her
and then conquer her like literally just
take her over from the inside out before
she even knows what happened
suddenly like all this power she has is
being used for his own ends and there's
nothing she can do to stop it what a
great redemption arc if like in the
middle of this whole great big huge
doctor strange multiverse of madness
thing it's doctor strange and all his
forces fighting against cathode from the
outside and wanda fighting against him
from the inside it'd be a great story
it'd be a great concept but nonetheless
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i'm excited about
this but i
i believe i wholeheartedly believe
cathone is coming for wanda and when he
gets a hold of her all bets are off
right any chance that anybody has of
like saving the earth is
done because for all the glitz and
glamour that thanos had with the
infinity gauntlet
that's absolutely nothing in comparison
to the power of catholic anyway guys
we're gonna bring this to an end make
sure you check out all of our videos
about wand division it's been a great
run i love it we're gonna have a few
other videos in store for you guys top
fives things like that highlighting our
favorite moments from wine division and
i will catch you all later
peace